E ai ai isso aí ó posso aqui só para mim
pais eram os jantares o passar quis era
uma jantar e agora o que é que eu vou ai
agora o que é que eu vou fazer
essa nós vamos cozinhar a famosa bolacha
ou biscoito da série screen the game é
uma das bolachas um dos participantes
tem que recortar uma forma dentro dela
para não perderem a sua própria vida
muito vocês que acompanham esta série já
sabem o que é que se trata se vocês não
viram se critica ainda ainda vão a tempo
é uma série que está bem popular na
Netflix até o seu que já viu olha eu
todo contente hoje vemos o último
episódio inclusive Então hoje nós vamos
aprender aqui juntos a receita super
fácil para este biscoito e no final
vamos ver se eu conseguiria sobreviver
ao desafio Se eu conseguir recrutar
aquela forminha dentro da bolacha eu
sobrevivo se não conseguir eu morro lá
então próximo dia pessoal vamos bora lá
então pessoal não adivinhar a nossa
receita de biscoito doce Kid game para
quem não sabe supostamente esta é um e
fez parte da infância de todos os
coreanos e era um joguinho onde ele
tinha que recortar Costa mente eu não
sei muito bem na cultura coreana mas
estou a tentar explicar o que eu sei que
nós também estamos indo retirar a forma
dentro da bolacha e até hoje e eu digo
uma coisa eu acho que é bastante fácil
de quebrar a bolacha toda ok então vamos
tentar fazer esse desafio aqui também e
vamos ver se eu tivesse dentro da série
tivesse dentro de um jogo real onde eu
tenho a minha vida posta em causa se eu
conseguiria sair Vivo ou não mas tô no
fim porque só apertamos primeiro fazer a
receita e cozinhar a bolacha receita é
muito fácil é
o cliente mas tem que um ponto que eu
não sei se eu consegui fazer que é o
ponto do açucar Mas também essa bolacha
é tipo só caramelo e caramelo nós
fazemos com açúcar e já temos aqui o
nosso fogãozinho por tá tudo o que eu
consigo cozinhar aqui está ligado fala É
a primeira vez que usar esse fogão
portátil porque eu fui comprar estes de
propósito para fazer este vídeo aqui
então se não funcionar ardeu com o vídeo
já já com quem é que estas pois as
espécies têm aqui agora é só
acho que não né eu não posso estúdio
Incredible primeiro passo vamos ter que
derreter o açúcar para eles se tornarem
caramelo Ok essa é a parte mais
complicada porque nós temos que estar
sempre mexer e sempre haverá um ponto do
açúcar eu vou tentar fazer com dois
copinhos deles eu acho que vai ser
suficiente para fazer talvez umas 4
bolachas mais do outro com opinião eu
acho que é super suficiente eu acho que
até a mais um
e para fazermos as formas para conseguir
jogar o jogo eu comprei aqui uma forma
de estrela que lá na série tem também o
círculo que também tem a série O
triângulo EA única que eu não consegui
encontrar foi do Chapéu e para quem viu
a série sabe do que estou a falar então
para substituir o chapéu pessoal vamos
colocar uma bem difícil que vai ser essa
flor imagina recortar isto aqui com uma
agulha eu vou usar uma agulha um palito
uma agulha uma agulha
vai ser mais difícil eu acho que mais
fácil é mesmo círculo eo triângulo mais
fácil é o triângulo obviamente é só
ativos já tá Bora lá prestar atenção ao
açúcar vamos ver como é que está
ok ainda não está acontecendo nada na já
está caramelizar aqui um pouquinho tá
ficar líquido já mas vamos esperar eu
quero sol tenho certeza que a pessoa que
não viu a série ainda está a pensar
porque é que o lado que está a fazer
isso com lados já é que eu faço Vejam a
série que eu recomendo a sério beijo
irritar incrível no último episódio é
mesmo
e até que uma notificação
a Deus
a escuridão e convidados agora
e não finalmente chegamos ao ponto do
caramelo só reparem só como ele fica
assim com esta coisa no meio acastanhado
sabem quando tiverem neste ponto vocês
desligam o fogão e colocam uma colher de
bicarbonato de sódio ou fermento mais ou
menos que isto assim
e o processo tem que ser muito rápido
antes que o açúcar segue e voltam ao
mexer Ok reparem só como já ganha outra
cor fica meio alaranjado
e misturam bem
e
não deixem queimar Ok é muito importante
sempre mexer sempre a mexer
assim ó e bora lá formar as nossas
bolachas agora
uma aqui
outra aqui
talvez dê para 31
a
calma acho que vamos conseguir três
pessoal e outra aqui tá lá vai lá vai lá
eu acho que deu para 3 pessoal
esta vai ficar mais pequena mas ainda
vamos fazer a quarta a quarta bolacha
eu acho que essa já não vai ficar muito
bem
ou não a colher como no Prado
e
como podem ver só seca muito rápido aqui
temos pessoal as nossas bolachas do
Speed game ainda falta colocar a forma
Ok mas vamos esperar secar um pouquinho
porque senão não vamos conseguir fazer a
forma então esperem aproximadamente 3 A
4 minutos só para deixar mais conhecer
um pouco que isso vocês podem fazer a
forma ela aqui no centro ainda tá muito
mal vamos parar um pouquinho mais essa
aqui do que acho que já ficou vamos
fazer a primeira forma a forma de flor
Bora lá é só colocar nos assim e apertar
um pouco não vamos apertar até o fim Ok
só até metade tem que sentir a bolacha
acho que é suficiente para aí já ficou a
forma que louco Ok esta vai ser mais
difícil estrela
E aí
é uma
em
Ok e esta vai ficar com o círculo
e até também já está ok
Um triângulo que só porque achas que eu
fiz para um fórum mais pequenas Ok então
esqueçam de criança fica para uma
próxima e agora vamos ver e agora é só
deixar ficar mais um pouquinho e estamos
prontos para começar o desafio do squid
game vejam como importante usar esse
papel porque assim Vocês conseguem
retirar
o biscoito muito mais facilmente Olha aí
igual e na série na série eles também
mostram o outro lado da bolacha Onde
fica a forma
mostra bem a forma dela
valor
esta também está pronta para só vai lá
pessoal as nossas taxas dos Games estão
prontas eu já tenho aqui a minha agulha
para fazer no desafio e agora vamos
fazer aqui uma espécie de Roleta Russa
vamos ver fala que não vai calhar e bora
lá em 3 2 1 vai E aí
e olha já
eu não morri porque o circo ainda lá
está
ainda minha mãe pode calma pessoal
basicamente o que eu tenho que fazer é
retirar esta forma mas Imaginem agora
que o meu era um círculo eu conseguiria
conseguiria passar o circo obviamente
que eu tenho que fazer isto com uma
agulha né mas enfim ser como eu passaria
esta não contou porque eu destruí a
bolacha Mas vamos tentar então a de
estrela e vou deixar essa aqui lá
a parte também
é bem fácil
realmente o outro eles lá fizeram
a não ser que eu tenho feitas bolachas
mais fáceis do mundo mas bora lá
experimentar em O que é que nós temos em
condições então que essa tela mais
difícil vai ser bem difícil meu agora eu
percebo porquê
e com água já
e olha
e eu morreria só nesta fase pessoal meu
Isto é muito difícil juro é por isso é
que eles ficam com a Agulha por que tu
arrastar só explicar tudo
e olha aí
o
tanto que eu quando vi a série eu pensei
porque não afastam a agulha bem mais
fácil mas mas agora percebo que é bem
complicado seu arrastar porque tem que
ter mesmo picando
Ok vou tentar só na mão porque a água é
impossível eu agora percebi o desespero
deles eu vou tentar aqui só na mão
ai parte a ponta
o álcool pion tá bem difícil
Ok com estas duas formas eu morreria
fácil já agora eu vou provar né
não
sabe aquele mel puro é muito bom sabe
é bom Apesar dela já está destruindo
aqui do lado Ainda temos a forma Ok e
vamos tentar mais uma vez com a agulha
E aí
bom
então
calma calma calma e destruiu lado eu
estava apoiar mas ainda temos a Flor
ainda temos a flor calma boa
E aí
Ah
tá dá pra ver deste lado
então
ainda estou vivo ainda estou em jogo
calma não
e
não está perfeita mas temos aqui a nossa
flor não
é aquele pessoal nesta fase o passaria
vivo a parceria a próxima fase e
basicamente é isso
e
amanhã você vem dormir é bem duro só
para caramelo e ele pessoal deixa eu vou
celulares aqui neste vídeo como devem
ser calculados de um trabalho fazer esta
receita Eu ainda fui buscar o seu cara
que fermento Oi estou cansada enfim
desta receita é um trabalho muito
ingredientes dizer só espero que tenha
gostado de Queimei até a Brasil